deux membres alors maintenant on va voir
ce que je pense qui est le vrai
chef-d'oeuvre de philidor c'est pas une
partie bon peut-être qu'elle joue des
parties de folie mais dans ce que j'ai
vu sur la base de truc c'est que bah
voilà il n'est pas éduqué digital à
l'époque et compagnie et est du coup
c'était plutôt de garder des traces de
ce que les parties en tout cas ça il a
très bien fait c'est donc philidor a
théorisé cette finale deux tours fou
entre tours et il a trouvé le lien ici
donc on sait qu'en jalton second tour
c'est nul mais dans certains cas de
figure notamment celui là quand le roi
de la défense se retrouve coupée sur la
bande avec le fou là en plus ça va être
un problème parce qu'ils ont un réseau
de maths temps quand faut-il savoir
gagner et filles aidant à trouver ça
donc il a fait
il a fait cette étude donc je rappelle
ainsi au xviiie siècle est évidemment à
l'époque y avait pas de pas d'ordi il
n'y avait pas de pas de table de base
bah rien de tout ça quand il a juste
fait ça tout seul avec sa tête sur son
échiquier rafraîchissant donc il a
publié sentent 149 cette finale et
c'était remarquable parce qu'en fait
juste il avait raison ça a passé le test
du temps on a pu vérifier que les
machines maintenant et tout et tout est
hors norme donc grand coup de chapeau
pour avoir pour avoir trouvé ça et je
rappelle aussi philidor était outre donc
joueur d'échecs c'était un peu son passe
temps mais il était aussi compositeur de
musique et donc oui j'ai un petit temps
libre dimanche qu'un jeu vous théorisé
ça ce tour fou compteur alors à voir
comment être heureux bien l échec tout
ici tout remonte alors qu'est ce qu'il
veut faire
il veut aller mater de ce côté donc les
noirs ce qu'ils font en général c'est
qu'ils vont enlever cette tour ici c'est
la meilleure case pour pouvoir suivre la
tour blanche celle ci débouche tour à
sept îles disent oui je veux dire en c2
nous assure toujours là je vais défendre
ici jusque là jusque là logique
l'autre option serait de se dire je
faire voilà je m'en vais de l'opposition
mais ça ne suffit pas à défendre
certaines fait retour ici menace maths
on comprend le tacle fou soit remplacé
contrôler cette case le roi contre les
deux ici tu aurais cheikh y aura 3 6 6 3
b 8 et le petit coup d'échec elle a
obligé d'aller au point évidemment
puisque si on fait rosser 8
on se prend fou de 6 on croit à 8 obligé
et la tourbe bessin alors toi bessengue
le problème c'est qu'on me laisse froid
ces sept on fait chacun a découvert que
tak la tour maintenant quoi faire si les
normands bouge la tour et puis trois et
sept ont fait échec au rabais 8 et torah
5 et valère matelas haut voilà grosso
modo ce qui peut se passer si une
entente ce type de défense
quand je rappelle qu'on est comme ça
m'est donc le mieux c'est de faire
tourner et l'a déjà premier coup hyper
subtil la part de phildar enfin
qu'est-ce qu'il ya découvert c'est qu'il
faut faire coût d'attenté nous avons
pourquoi parce que les bars vont devoir
à nouveau bouger ses deux tours et sur
les allées sur le gaz beaucoup moins
favorable donc à noter que la seconde
rangée elle est pas mal
la première ensuite et la 3d manger
c'est la pire on va comprendre pourquoi
donc là bon j'ai fait 3 2 sans faire
exprès mais je vous dire que c'est une
bêtise parce qu'on m'a très bien sûr
c'est pour ça que la tour doit rester le
long de la colonne alors tous rage sept
que peuvent faire les noirs de rester
sur la colle à merveille à tours ou
essayer de s'enfuir avec laure un
problème s'il ya pas de suite
on voit ici devant la seimat soutien à
gaz pour assez vite c'est la même chose
on mais de l'autre côté du pont peut
donner la tour et on se bat et là donc
on comprend que les noirs ou qu'un seul
enfin que deux coups d'attentes 7 euros
3 au tournant parce que bien sûr s'ils
repartent lao ont fait tour à 7
et là y'a plus personne pour venir
défendre ici ok donc tour autres tours 1
on va regarder de 3,6 passes ces deux
moins bons moments asus résistants mais
pourquoi alors on va faire cet échec
maintenant le roi deux options est ce
qu'on vend 8 aces confiance et 8,8 mieux
sur vence et huit tours à 7
toujours les mêmes schémas de ce matelas
et là le gros problème de cette tour sur
la troisième c'est que la case pour
revenir défendre mais vite
cb 3 mai est contrôlé par le fonds du
coup il ya juste pas de défense et les
prochains coups se trouve à huit matchs
dont on croit ses huit pairs sur le
champ faut faire re 8 mieux du coup on
part là bas maintenant pourquoi d'un
buste et chèques avant et qu'il ya plus
tour la tour là pour défendre parce que
leurs ouailles plus au contact
donc la torah 8 et la menace de maths du
coup quoi faire là il faut fuir il ya
échec obligé de revenir pour évidemment
si on va là-bas pour une découverte
la tour donc re vite et le cou à retenir
taux refi 4 fini pourquoi tu aurais fiat
alors 2 1 on s'enlève de f 7 ou le roi
attaqué quelques parle à tort aux
menaces pouces et 6 on ferait échec le
roi dans la qu'une case cd vite et en
fret aurait fuite qui va mater deuxième
truc
donc disons que les noirs voient ils
font raser vite comme ça et victor la
presse évite donc ça y reviennent en
ayant l'impression de départ maintenant
on joue ce coup de fouet 4 l'autre à
travers la tour ici donc c'est qu'on
défend alexandre obstrue la tour on
remue menace tour la meute bon qu'on l'a
déjà dit un rossi suffit pas à défendre
et or et suit donc le coup le roi
revient sur ses pas fou échec
voilà et on va mater l'homme donc ouais
voyez ce truc ce truc très jolis seins
ce petit coup de deux tours être 4
revient et il y arrive à faire en fait
c'est très bon et si v noir pour y
déposer s'il tente tour des trois ont
fait tant g4 à ce moment là menace
matelas à eau et une nouvelle fois comme
c'était le capteur avec la case b3 là
c'est la case f3 la tombe pas revenir
pour défendre puisque le fou défend
voilà voilà
alors ça c'était pour tours troyes
direct mais voyez déjà c'est compliqué
là on n'avait qu'une petite variante est
tout rond à mieux donc on comprend
pourquoi parce que la tour pourraient
avoir accès à des cases qu'elle n'a pas
accès soit trop dérangé parce que le
flou les contrôles et on va pouvoir
faire des menaces de match grâce à leur
tour un plus fort mais on va te trouve
un moyen 9 ans l'autre de l'atterrisseur
troisième rangée et et de refaire le
même
le même schéma bien tomber cette menace
mathis bons français et il a le cou à
connaître ou b3 alors four b3 très bien
parce que on empêche ordinaire il n'y a
pas d'échec bien sûr et on remet les
noirs un peu dans le même cas de figure
p nîmes hier que la tour doit axer sur
la colonne sait s'ils vont n'importe où
ailleurs
il ya juste matelas haut et sur la
colonne sic ou une case de disponibles
n'a pas tant que ça en fait impossible
pas possible pas possible pas possible
pas possible donc à ces trois on sait
c'est la case d3 de manger normalement
pas bonne ou ses huit pour lac de torcy
on va passer de l'autre côté et on va
mater là bas il ya juste rien à faire
donc pour ces huit c'est vite vu
il restaure ces trains est aussi autre
option serait de faire voilà mais on
recommence comme avec le tour f4 tout à
l'heure mais de l'autre côté c'est tombé
4 on veut faire faux échec aura bouge
dans la peau mate
donc voilà tour ici donc ils font le
petit coup d'attentes ont par là bas
tour 1 et x 4 terminé on tient cette
case du coup y'a jamais la tour qui va
revenir on veut mater là-bas le roi par
ici on voit le coupé ils ont tu fasses
échec on couvre et maintenant bah quoi
faire parce que toi là c'est la menace
si le roi s'en va on revient de ce côté
et on a noté un sas et des jolies
manoeuvres mais en fait on problème tout
marche c'est très belle harmonie entre
le fou la tour en fait ça marche très
bien
du coup je peux et 3 on va tenter dans
ces trois communes coups de défense
étaient un peu lourdes manoeuvres ont
fait faux le 6 comme ça en menacent
toujours là aux mathes puisque les temps
pour parvenir les noirs offertoires
d'être en échec on ramène le fou eh ben
ils vont revenir sur leurs pas pour
défendre là mais en fait maintenant afin
de symétrie par rapport à ce qu'on
habite à leurs fins c'est-à-dire
quasiment la même chose
l'art tech3 qu'on a vus ou au tout début
donc comment les toiles en c3 mais c'est
à peu près les mêmes amis ont fait échec
donc leur a donné
on a déjà dit si le roi vient de ce côté
on va les mater par là puisque tours là
ne marche pas bien sûr le fou défend la
case donc point ces huit tours h7
menace mat au rabais et 8 ont fait
tomber cette leroy revient ici est en
fait tombé car tout à leur tour être cap
maintenance tomber quatre rois des huit
on intercepte la même chose il vient on
colle l'échec y vient et en voilà donc
tout ça
bah il a tout trouvé en 1749 quand même
et et ça marche mais ça marche après ce
que ce que je vous conseille c'est
devrait entraîner de voir la vidéo il
parle d'aller sur le dribble de check
point com et vous vous entraînez contre
l'ordinateur vont jouer parce que en
fait ça gagne en farsi vous savez faire
vous savez faire bravo m kasparov
carlson la partie en face et donc plus
qu'à défendre la position de départ donc
le jour c'est se faire ça par coeur
c'est très bien mais ça demande de
l'entraînement parce que on peut vite se
tromper ça demande des petites meufs
précise tout ça mais mais sympa sympa ce
truc à savoir faire
voilà bah écoute et j'espère que ça vous
a plu maintenant on va changer de
joueurs on a peu fait le tour de
philidor c'est un peu de temps et la
prochaine fois on va parler de la
bourdonnais voilà allez à bientôt ciao